a little off the
started my name is Daniel Boltzmann
right
you know in the history department and
on behalf
Ginsu who's the chair of the Council on
East Asian Studies but unfortunately way
right now doing reeving research in Hong
Kong I want to welcome you all to the
21st annual John wo lecture in Japanese
studies the whole lecture was
established with the generous support of
mrs. Robin Hall in memory of her husband
of some 55 years John Whitney Hall who
was as I'm sure you will know a towering
figure in the development of Japanese
studies in the United States and of
course here at Yale after World War two
I'm various notes here about professor
halls many accomplishments but I have
been given permission to refer you all
to the back page of the handout which
will give you more information about
professor Hall and his career so as I
have already said this is the
twenty-first year that a distinguished
figure in the field of Japanese studies
in the United States has been invited to
deliver the John W all lecture it is
however the first time that the
invitation has gone to one of our own
Yale colleagues and this I think is an
indication of the very deep combination
of esteem respect and gratitude that we
all feel towards professor bill Kelley
like John W Hall professor Kelley
completed his undergraduate degree at
Amherst College before taking his PhD in
socio-cultural anthropology at Brandeis
he joined the Yale faculty in 1980 just
a few years before professor Hall
retired and in the decades since then I
think it's safe to say that no one has
done more to ensure both the
institutional and more importantly the
intellectual vitality of Japanese
studies at Yale and bill Kelley
you're not here to listen to me today
and in the little bit of time I have I
don't think I can possibly do justice to
the full range of bills contributions to
the field of Japanese studies as a
teacher as an administrator and of
course as
but let me just say that he is someone
whose work has continually helped to
define new research agendas and
possibilities for the study of Japan
this is true of his foundational work on
irrigation leaks and water control his
deeply nuanced study of popular protests
across the 19th century his articles on
class formation and contemporary society
his brilliant new book on professional
baseball and the Hanshin Tigers and he's
now two decades of accumulated work on
various aspects of sport and body
culture in East Asia so particularly in
2020 the year in which Tokyo will host
its second Olympic Games who could be
better qualified to deliver the annual
Hall lecture than Professor Bill Kelly
[Applause]
well thank you so very much Danny it was
actually a very touching occasion for me
Jack Hall was one of my intellectual
heroes and as Danny intimated my first
years at Yale in the 1980s overlapped
with his final years in his career here
at Yale and he was an enormous li
stimulating demanding supportive mentor
to me and many others and so to be able
to speak in the hall lecture means a lot
at the end of my own career at Yale with
the council and the anthropology
department my two homes here and the
colleagues and the students that have
generously given of their time to come
out today now Jack Hall did not much
care for sports he did mountain climbing
in the White Mountains and the rest of
New England but organized sports as far
as I know didn't really interest him so
I have to have a kind of holographic
figure of Jack Hall in the corner here
to speak to somebody who doesn't care
about sports about and around this event
that will be opening seven months
day counting the International Dateline
in July 24th in Tokyo in 2020 and I want
a jackhole style Japanese style and
giving you a brief resume I want to talk
about the Tokyo 2020 Olympics basically
in two frameworks one in the framework
of the Olympics themselves in the
Olympic movement and the ways in which
the very distinctive qualities of the
Olympics helped to shape what is taking
place now has been taking place for
several years and will open in the
formerly in the opening ceremonies on
July 24th and because there is so much
effort by those who are planning and
promoting and producing the 2020 Tokyo
Olympics to tie those Olympics to the
previous Summer Olympics in Tokyo back
in 1964 the second frame of reference I
think that's important in understanding
this year is the Tokyo 1964 Olympics and
what they meant at the time and what
people are trying to make them a meet
meet meet now mega event scholars turned
scholars like to use when they're
referring to sports the two global
mega events are the Summer Olympics and
the soccer world cup at least the men's
world cup both of them share two
qualities they happen every four years
and both of them are run by gigantic
organizations with enormous ideological
pretensions with very little
transparency and not a fair bit of
corruption otherwise the FIFA World Cup
and the Summer Olympics are very
different beasts themselves the FIFA
World Cup is about a single sport the
world's most popular sport soccer in
which some 36 teams will assemble it's
hosted by a country over three weeks
some 850 soccer players are going to be
playing a single game
meeting in a final the Olympics the
Summer Olympics the largest multi-sport
gathering in the world in Tokyo as you
can see some 33 sports that are run over
multiple events featuring over 11,000
athletes just as many media will be
gathering over those over those two
weeks the logistics for organising
something like that are gargantuan
Olympian and contrast it considerably
with with with with with the World Cup
unlike soccer whose rules whose teams
whose players are known to billions
around the world most of the sports
almost all over the sports that the
Olympics are not followed are not even
well-known by most of us the second
quality of organizing something like the
Summer Olympics is how do you educate
how do you draw in the audiences to
justify for example the four billion US
dollars that NBC has paid in order to
perform in order to broadcast the most
recent Olympics it's an enormous
challenge to generate some interest let
alone passion in things like Madison
cycle what is Madison cycling or archery
or a water polo or four-man kayaking I
mean think about the world's largest
global mega event is based on 33 sports
that most people know very little about
care very little about and only
encounter once every four years so the
remarkable qualities to the Olympics
that distinguish that certainly from
FIFA and most other most of their events
now what I want to do today is not to
explain Madison cycling or for man kya
ki or any of the sports but to try to
look beyond the sports themselves to
what
this thing is this not just the Olympics
but the Olympic movement that's what it
identifies itself as capital o capital M
and the particular forms that those that
Olympic movement will take in Tokyo in
seven months if we follow the Olympic
logic of five there are at least five
distinctive qualities of the Olympic
movement that are important in unpacking
on the nature of the games and that
which comes before and after there are
lots of people in this building who
study global formations global
structures global organizations it
always surprises me that very few focus
on the IOC it's one of the earliest one
of the largest one of the most
consequential transnational sovereign
organizations in the world it yields
enormous for analytical insight into the
nature of global governance its origins
as some of you know were not
particularly propitious it was a single
individual this rather obscure French
aristocrat and educator in the 1890s who
had the idea stimulated by various
factors to organize and Olympics
gathered a few like-minded souls and
formed a committee the International
Olympic Committee that put on the
initial modern Olympics in Athens in
1896 the Panathenaic Stadium some of you
may have visited you can still see some
of the events were less well organized
the swimming was held in the polluted
harbour port of Piraeus amid the ferries
going to and from the various Greek
islands but from this somewhat
inauspicious beginning sprang over a
hundred and twenty-five years one of the
largest global transnational
organizations in the world the details
are too fuzzy it's not the details it's
the color the sense of the center of the
IRC is up here with the president
and the for vice-presidents as you can
see like a heel secret society it's
entirely self selecting self
perpetuating and not particularly
transparent in its top governance from
that governance spreads some 30
different Commission's about ethics and
finance and and and and other things
directly controlled by the IOC
Secretariat it has its own bureaucracy
it has its own court to adjudicate
issues involving licensing and athletic
performance this is a textual a trans
transposition of that graph and you can
see the extent that the iOS are the
tentacles that the IOC has spread across
the globe through the performance of
these of these of these sports down to
the direct contracts that it makes which
eats of the host cities that involve
often the host city giving up
legislative and sovereign rights for the
duration of the Olympics it's a kind of
state of exception that's created every
four years it's not just an
organizational behemoth but it is a
global marketing brand probably the most
valuable global sports brand in the
world
the IOC itself has created a top tier of
some 13 exclusive sponsors initially
from euro-american corporations now
increasingly East Asia based
multinationals from which it gains its
revenue local host cities have a whole
series of temporary sponsors in order to
generate their own revenue but it's not
even that kind of commercial licensing
and sponsorship but rather broadcasting
that is the source of three-quarters of
the ioc revenue as you can see from
roughly 68 los angeles particularly from
the volume of revenue that is gained
through broadcasting rights around the
world really supports the ioc it now has
its own Broadcasting Service so it's
replaced commercial broadcast
in feeding the Olympic Games and
everything else to its to its licensees
given all of that the other side of the
Olympic movement seems to be a glaring
hypocritical contradiction all sports
are many sports make claims for building
character or displaying character or
teaching life lessons but there's no
tennis ISM and there's no hockey ISM and
there's no baseball ISM but there is
Olympism for a hundred years 125 years
there has been an effort by the IOC and
and Olympic leaders to articulate a
full-blown philosophy about the power of
sport through the filter of the Olympics
in order to create the conditions of
peace and harmony and teamwork and
building and it's done through the
speeches is done through text books it's
done through events that it does
continually year after year more
importantly this kind of Olympism as
philosophy has come to be expressed
through the familiar pageantry that
anyone turning on the television during
the games themselves will encounter from
the opening ceremonies to the closing
ceremonies it was de Cooper Kane himself
who invented the iconic five ring
Olympic a symbol lots of theories one is
that these are the five continents each
distinct but interlocked through the
power of Olympism to have this common
human experience he also created a motto
the Olympic flame appeared in the 1920s
Hitler wanted to have the flame brought
from Mount Olympus up through the
Balkans to Berlin and so he created the
torch in the torch relay which became
essential in the lead-up to the games
themselves the ceremonies the emblems
the flag the anthem the oath the Creed
and now every host city for every games
will create an entire panoply
of medals and mascots pictograms for the
events these are the medals for Tokyo
2020 which are very proudly done with
recycled recycled materials to express
this Olympus philosophy now of
sustainability so that there is this
Olympism in addition to the Olympic or
the Olympic brand I'll come back to that
later it's more than just a
contradiction it's a kind of a mutual
construction of various implications of
the Olympics there's also a limping
gender as you can see there were no
women in the earliest Olympics the
Cooper tan and his time did not did not
feel that female that women were
appropriate in public athletic display
women started to appear in the 1920s in
the 1930s it was really around the time
of the Tokyo 64 Olympics that they were
given more and more exposure more and
more resources more and more equal
billing in Tokyo 2020 it's expected that
the percentage will be around around 50%
why is that meaningful well in the
United States since the 1970s we've had
title 9 title 9 brought women brought
girls and women into sports it had an
enormous impact on the American Sports
Cape the rest of the world had the
Olympics it was the Olympics that threw
the opportunity to to perform and the
incentives on countries to to develop
programs for female athletes that they
might bring medals home for their
country that really did more than
anything else to increase the level of
female participation in athletics
particularly in elite athletics has been
enormous leap or important as a force
for bringing a women's sports into some
kind of recognition paradeen in in the
Olympics if not elsewhere it also
created the question of who is male and
who is fee
or at least who is an Olympic male and
who is an Olympic female I'll come back
to that later but as some of you know
the controversies in having created this
not only multi-sport but male-female
venue creates the demands and the
controversies over making that kind of
distinction and defending some kind of
sexual binary fourth quality is the IOC
has not only come to embrace female
athletics come to embrace what is now
called Paralympics abled athletes and
disabled athletes it was around the time
of the Tokyo 64 Olympics I'll come back
to that also later in which the the so
called handicap games were reaiiy denta
fide as the Paralympics and foot on in
the same venue immediately following
immediately following the Olympics it's
the only a major multi-sport event in
the world that has beginning to pair
so-called abled athletic performances
and disabled athletic performance is
calling into question what that sort of
distinction is as well in fact at the
Tokyo Paralympics that immediately
follow the Tokyo Olympics they're even
more events although fewer sports and
half the athletes than there are in the
Olympics because of the different
categories that the Paralympic Committee
has created to try to ensure different
kinds of competition in these in these
sports and finally to the fifth very
distinctive quality of the Olympics that
set it apart from most other sports
events and organizations is where you
call Olympic time Olympic temporalities
we turn on the TV set next July 24th and
we might watch the Olympics for two
weeks and then four years later we'll do
the same thing but the Tokyo Olympics
began in about 2004 Tokyo Olympics have
been going on for over 15 years
when Ishihara the nationalist governor
of Tokyo had in mind that Tokyo should
host the 2016 Olympics he started
mobilizing lobbying generating resources
and support in Tokyo but to do that it
took a long time Tokyo was one of the
city's bidding for 2016 it lost out but
it immediately turned around and started
mobilizing for 2020 he takes a long time
to generate the local support in order
to make a bid takes a long time to to
put that bid forward to the IOC and then
be selected the selection for Tokyo was
in 2013 so there in six years in which
the Tokyo 2020 Olympics have been going
on in order to reach that point seven
months from now the game themselves are
over in in the blink of an eye
the legacy continues the Tokyo in 1964
Olympics are still going on in the minds
and and Mills of many other people the
other quality of Olympic temporalities
is that each of these Olympics has the
same kind of cycle and if these cycles
overlap each other in very complicated
ways driving one another influencing one
another Tokyo 2020 to a certain extent
is looking forward to the Beijing Winter
Olympics in 2022 certainly to Paris in
2024 comparatively is looking backwards
to Rio most recently to London to
Beijing certainly coming back to Tokyo
64 so but the Olympic of the Olympics
has created this very complicated sense
of overlays of history and temporalities
that are important for each and every of
these single Olympics now all of these
the qualities of the Olympics feed in to
help to shape the ways in which the
Tokyo 2020 Olympics are being put
together the other frame that I
mentioned at the outset was this effort
to harken back to the experience and the
effects
the Olympics in tow in 1919 1964 and
reviving the spirit of the 64 Olympics
is a phrase that's been used over and
over by those who would promote and
produce the Olympics the Olympics this
year so let me turn to 64 and then come
forward to 2020 we're in 64 the phrase
that was used most always to do to sum
up the image that it was trying to
project and the legacy that it hoped to
leave in the aftermath of the Olympics
was a sense of Japan now almost 20 years
at the end of the Pacific War World War
two being recognized once again by the
international order and particularly the
West the ural American West as a normal
nation and the in Tokyo Olympics were
aimed to demonstrate that once again it
was in a position as a prosperous and
peaceful nation to join the table of
other nations
well again the Olympic logic of 5 if
there were 5 images most indelible in
the experience of the Tokyo 64 Olympics
it would be these and let me talk about
each one in order this was you know that
tableau at every opening ceremony when
the last of the relay runners enter the
stadium circle the the stadium and then
go up the steps to light the Olympic
torch of course the final sacred Runner
was this 19 year old boy who had been
born on the edge of Hiroshima on the day
the bomb was dropped and this was an
iconic moment a meaningful moment for
the Japanese it was a victim of the
nucleo of the of the atomic bomb the IOC
to that point had demanded that the head
of state open each of the games
all of the host cities Japan had no head
of state and the Ministry of Education a
very craftily persuaded the IOC to
suspend its ruling and allow the Emperor
who was not head of state but a symbol
of the people to appear opening the
games as patron of the games rather than
head of state Japan had no military it
had self-defense forces but the
acrobatic skywriting team of the Air
Force self-defense forces did the five
rings over the stadium in the midst of
us of the ceremony all sorts of ways in
which nationalists of the Kimio
anthem was sung the Japanese flag was
raised at opening ceremony itself was
this moment in which there was a kind of
sanitization of the important symbols of
Japanese nationalism that had been
suppressed for years years before
foreign media were brought in and given
very carefully cultivated opportunities
photo opportunities and sometimes
interview opportunities with the
imperial family and Emperor Hirohito was
incensed repackaged through middle-class
domesticity as a very different emperor
than the euro-american nations who
arrived in Tokyo had had experienced up
to that point and this is the figure
with with Hirohito and I can heat
through another heat though the next
three Emperor's the current Emperor who
will preside over the 2020 Olympics I'm
looking through this family photograph
album in this is quite odd photograph of
the of the imperial family the second
thing that happened in this image of the
bullet train that we all use when we
entered Japan the first bullet train of
Shinkansen was completed made his
journey from Tokyo Station to shin-osaka
on October 1st and it represented the
ways in which the Olympics set in motion
allowed
this massive transformation of the
infrastructure particularly of central
Tokyo but metropolitan Tokyo more
generally the Shinkansen the intercity
railroads but also over a hundred
kilometres of highways in metropolitan
Tokyo often done as the elevated
expressways that we still use throughout
Tokyo done in an in done in a deliberate
engineering strategy to rise over the
existing streets also it allowed them to
avoid having to buy land for the the the
highways themselves
honey the airport was made an
International Airport international
hotels government agency Tokyo became a
vertical city in 1964 where it had been
much more of a horizontal City - to that
point as you can see one way in 1964 I
talked about this transformation as one
between sites OC SIA smelly Toshiya City
from a smelly City to coke Saito see an
international City these are residents
of Tokyo taking that what was then a
ferry
up and down the the the Sumida River and
if I don't know that there was anybody
here who was in Tokyo in 1964 I wasn't
but it was by all reports a very
unpleasant experience highly polluted
and so again it was not just
infrastructure construction but it was
redoing the sanitation and much else of
Tokyo it had this infrastructure
transformations
a number of unintended consequences
originally the Olympics were planned
with venues on the western edge of Tokyo
because the American occupation forces
and then the American military still
controlled large areas in central Tokyo
that they had in turn had taken from the
Imperial Army and the Imperial motoki
was very much a military city throughout
the 20th century with parade grounds and
barracks and and military buildings all
over the central city in the negotiate
nations with the Americans over getting
some land to build some of the stadiums
in some of the facilities the Japanese
initially plan to take the bases that
were on the edge of the city by surprise
in 1961 the Americans decided to turn
over most of the central land that it
was occupying including most famously
the so-called what it had renamed the
Washington Heights complex that was used
for military housing and schools and
other sort of operations which became
the athletes village the gymnasium the
NHK Center are still standing today so
there was a m'l Tokyo became a city of
athletic facilities rather than a
ciliate city of military parade grounds
another of the unintended consequence of
this point of the Shinkansen through its
planners or at least to its promoters
was that it would enable people in Tokyo
to easily reach Osaka and then as it was
extended to other cities in fact the
effect was the opposite the Shinkansen
enabled people from Osaka to get to
Tokyo once they got to Tokyo they stayed
in Tokyo there's the same content and
other intercity transportation
developments in the 1960s created the
latest and still continuing movement of
much of the regional population and
cities into Tokyo the Ono Bernice on
coming from the countryside but also
corporations that moved from Osaka into
Tokyo so among the the the
transformations not all of the not all
of the effects were those intended by
those who actually actually built them a
third was the use of architecture and
the design of the facilities of the
Olympics themselves to make a statement
about or to to lead Japan into what was
then the dominant architectural style of
Euro America kind of international style
of modernism but with Japanese
inflections of materials and design and
and
friends telling you here some of you
know was influenced by the Yale hockey
rink that had been right up the street
that had been opened in 1958 that and a
couple of other buildings inspired
probably the most famous of the Olympic
buildings of the time this is the
interior another was the martial arts
hall that Yamada designed was built
again to try to express this this
calmness conjoining of an international
style and traditional Japanese
inflections there was not just
architecture but aesthetics it was the
first time that the games were done in a
non European language speaking for the
visitors couldn't understand Japanese
signs so the Japanese organizers
developed pictographs of all of the
different events and from that point
forward every Olympics has competed to
design evermore distinctive and pleasing
pictograms for its events along with
posters there were posters before but
the graphic designers that were
mobilized by the Japanese created new
standards of poster art for the Olympics
the each become a documentary that
appeared shortly after the Olympics that
was referencing Leaney rife installs
equally notorious and famous documentary
of the Berlin examples was another
example finally Tokyo was cleaned up in
other ways as well
the yuckers of bosses were persuaded to
open training camps for all of their
members outside of town so that they
could clean the city of the opera's
therefore the period of the Olympics
buckets of yellow flags were put at all
the intersections to help the tourists
navigate from the Tokyo traffic and
those buckets still remain in Tokyo taxi
drivers were instructing in various
forms of etiquette he's he's not wearing
white clothes but white gloves began to
appear honking was out late in all sorts
of ways the effort was to use the
material and hospitality into in
structures of Tokyo in order to present
the joy to reimagine Japan a fourth
image is this photograph of the gold
medal contest of the game between the
Japanese national team and the Soviet
Union it can be read and was read in
sort of Cold War political terms Japan
as the ally of the u.s. against the
Soviet Union the Japanese were actually
already world champions they had won the
championship in Moscow in 1962 the
Moscow press was what was what was quite
taken by the Japanese team they called
them the typhoon of the East the
Japanese media thought typhoons come and
go and these are forever so they were
called The Witches of the East and that
was the moniker that remained with this
Japanese team through this through this
gold medal the media had been following
this particular team the women's
volleyball team for about six years in
its training it was largely except for
two members the corporate team of honey
bow corporation which was a major
textile now a cosmetic corporation the
meanings of this photo and this team
actually had less to do with
international geopolitics and more to do
with this was the decade in which
companies like ton ago in fact most
manufacturing companies depended heavily
on recruiting graduates from junior high
schools often as groups from particular
schools who were brought to the
dormitories of the leading manufacturing
companies and this team was a
demonstration to Japan particularly the
Japanese parents and to the graduates
themselves of the attractiveness of
these companies and life in these
companies it was the discipline but it
was also the sort of the recreation and
the acclaim that they were able to gain
from this this bold mill has enormous
sort of demonstration effect on this
pattern of employment it also
because this is 80% of the Japanese
tuning into this game the the Telus
televised views of Tokyo was an enormous
attraction for the youth of Japan in the
1960s in drawing them particularly to
Tokyo but also to other cities as well
this particular team together with the
OMA Rd Giants brought a whole genre of
manga that continues today on spoil
sports clones oh I'm saying Headley is a
enormous effect domestically finally the
Paralympics at that time were something
of an afterthought but their
significance can't be overlooked what
was disabled at the time particularly in
Japan but also in Europe were those who
had been injured in the war the soldiers
still in Tokyo lined the streets without
adequate social services from the
government seeking arms and the sense of
disability was still connected quite
heavily to the veterans of the war
Paralympics went a long way to
reimagining a sense of disability as a
much broader set of conditions and in
fact the Imperial Household particularly
Akihiko took an interest in using the
Paralympics as a way of trying to
generate some kind of social support
some kind of new policies for the
disabled in Japan so in lots of is a
saying in in in those ways it was not so
much that Japan was demonstrating itself
as a normal nation but it was really the
collectively creating a new historical
baseline of that society
for post-war Japan disguising replacing
a sense of Japan as
for its military imperialism for the
devastation after the war replacing that
with a very new view of Tokyo and
through Tokyo with Japan itself as the
legacy of 64 given that you can imagine
some of the attractiveness of that
legacy or a selective legacy of 64
Olympics for those who were again
planning and promoting the 2020 Olympics
part of it is personal that is many of
the senior figures in Japan at the
moment Abhi's a bit himself is a bit too
young but you know we're teenagers in
the 1960s the 1964 Olympics watching the
Olympics watching Japan watch the
Olympics had a powerful impact on their
sense of their country and so this
effort now in in 2022 to recreate from
their gauzy childhood nostalgia a sense
of what the Tokyo 64 Olympic works very
works very powerfully in fact that's
probably not what's going on in the
general population beyond that
particular particular cohort rather I
think there are at least three other
sort of agendas that are particularly at
work prominently in the run-up to the
2020 Olympics on the regional which is
to say the East Asia regional level on
the national level and on the local
Tokyo level first of all in 1964 Japan
was looking to the west looking to
Europe into America to impress to be
drawn into that particular international
order geopolitically the 2020 Olympics
are much more about East Asia than your
than euro America and you can see the
East Asian countries have have become
one of the central forces in the Olympic
movement from the late 20th century into
the 21st and
movement with their hosting with their
participation with their commercial
sponsorship with their TV audiences but
they are also competing with one another
for the prestige of hosting using what
all of the elements of the Olympics soft
power has always been to me a somewhat
mushy concept but if it is ever to find
a referent it is the Olympics and the
use that East Asian Nations have made of
hosting vying to host and produce these
these Olympics and you can imagine the
tensions that are rising in East Asia
are stronger now than they have been for
decades
whether it's North Korea South Korea
Japan China Japan the repressions in
Hong Kong and Taiwan and the wiggers I
mean all of these tensions find
expression in efforts to project the
Olympics or to [ __ ] the Olympics South
Koreans for example as some of you know
have raised enormous protests over the
potential use of the old Japanese flag
it was the flag of the Imperial military
forces it's also the flag of lots of
other things that are a less innocuous
at the moment but the South Koreans are
demanding this fight not appear in the
games or among spectators there was the
incident in London again a South Korean
athlete who brought out this banner to
to suggest that the the islands were
Korean and not Japanese
so the potential to use the heavy sort
of pageantry ceremonialism symbolism of
the games in order to pursue none of
these political frictions has been
welded you know the South Koreans
suggest that they're going to bring all
of their food and all of their chefs
because they can't trust Japanese foods
after Fukushima the Japanese of course
are obviously
quite irritated processing I mean all of
these seemingly if not trivial at least
somewhat symbolic fights have direct
references and direct effects on the
ongoing political frictions and economic
struggles among these East Asian
countries so the 2020 Olympics are much
more set within the current geopolitics
of East Asia than something wider than
something wider than that second thing
that is of an important theme driving
the ways in which the 2020 Olympics are
defended and attacked our national that
is to Japan the decade that has just
ended last month doesn't have a name but
certainly it was bookended by the triple
disasters that began on 311 2011 and
will end the opening ceremonies of 2020
the disasters in Tohoku that tsunami the
earthquake in Fukushima that began this
decade and the demands of creating the
Olympics in 2020 the obvious criticisms
that have been played out for years now
are the ways in which the Olympics are
unnecessary brain have diverted the
resources that were essential to
rebuilding toku and resolving some of
the Fukushima problems and the the
promoters of the 2020 Olympics have
responded by trying to repackage them as
the recovery reconstruction games again
suggesting with allusions to Tokyo and
the 64 Olympics as a way of rebuilding
the recovery of Tokyo from the ravages
of that of that of that war another way
of putting it is this is a decade that
moves from disaster capitalism to
celebration capitalism Tocqueville may
suffer from the budget that has been
diverted for Tokyo but many of the major
corporations
that invested heavily they have gained
heavily from the recovery efforts in tow
who are the same ones that are profiting
from the buildup in Tokyo itself Naomi
Klein some of you know is this wonderful
characterization of the the state of
exception that is created by these
large-scale disasters that suspend many
of the normal rules of operating and
allow capitalists and other developers
to come in and to take advantage of
these recovery efforts well Jonathan boy
HOF has an obverse of that which is a
kind of celebration capitalism the ways
in which particularly the Olympics to a
certain extent the World Cup open up
opportunities for investment under
special conditions that yield
extraordinary profits and perhaps the
the strongest example in Tokyo 2020 is
the construction of what is initially
the athletes village but will also then
become through a consortium of real
estate and construction companies one of
the largest apartment complexes in in
Tokyo Bay the irony is that as the IOC
itself has come to emphasize
sustainability and circumscribed
investment in these Olympics the
consequence is that it focuses the
investment on a smaller and smaller area
that as almost all of the money that is
going into the Tokyo Olympics is going
into central central Tokyo which is only
going to exacerbate the trend that began
in 1964 with the now hyper concentration
of population and recently Tokyo Japan
is the the the country in the world with
the largest as you can see the largest
concentration of its populations in the
capital metropolitan region and the 2020
Olympics will only further intensify
this movement of population and insta
toons into the Tokyo area it seems odd
that the the third the final agenda that
is driving the Tokyo bid and it is an
anxiety about its status as a global
city now this may seem odd to some of
you I mean we have the US News and World
Report and all these American colleges
and universities get more and more
nervous over the years about their exact
standing in the rankings of these
colleges when global cities have their
own metrics their own rankings that that
actually seemed to have more purchase on
Metropolitan officials politicians and
corporations and institutions than we
might imagine and for some years Tokyo
has actually been fairly stable this was
a foreign policy magazine started this
in the ER in the 1990s got Saskia Sassen
and other scholars to help them design a
global cities index of various
dimensions and every year or every
several years its revised and this has
become apparently enormous ly important
in Tokyo metropolitan circles in
thinking about Tokyo's position visa vie
the other cities of the world
particularly its political its economic
dominance may be secure but the cultural
amenities and the social policies always
seem to be somewhat somewhat fragile
it's not so much looking up as looking
down it may not think that it's going to
overtake Paris or London or New York but
it's increasingly looking at Hong Kong
and Singapore and Beijing and other East
Asian capitals as it tries to secure its
its ranking and the Olympics become a
way in which not just physical
infrastructure but other kinds of
adjustments to the quality of life in
the the in Tokyo can be it can be pushed
in things as simple as signage that some
of you have known if you've gone in
Japan over the year
the accommodations Act which now
requires certain kinds of barrier free
hotel rooms I mean other sorts of
physical public facilities auditoriums
that this fleet of Toyota taxis that
were rolled out to great fanfare last
year with a barrier free access the
current metropolitan governor quake is
particularly determined to reform the
power-pole pollution in tokyo as you can
see as anyone who's coming to tokyo
knows manager or navigating the warrant
of power poles is one of the distinctive
features of their city so the olympics
become in a sense a way of packaging
many of these issues that are difficult
to pursue individually and respond to
the anxiety that that that tokyo feels
as a as a global as a global city those
both on the the regional on the national
on the metropolitan level in which these
sorts of agendas have been identified in
our pursuit now i haven't said anything
about the actual controversies
themselves the particular issues that
that have arisen massive budget overruns
it's more like deliberate low-balling of
the budgets that are probably three or
four times what was initially announced
the diversion of the funds the IOC chair
was forced to resign the bribery the
corruption that is uncovered with every
Olympic cycle and it turned out the
initial winning Tokyo poster logo had
been plagiarized off the internet from a
Dutch designer Prime Minister Abe a
decided that the the starchitect is a
hadees' design was unappealing it sort
of said to look like a bicycle helmet
it was overturned and they turned to a
prominent Japanese architect to replace
that
of course as of last week you know the
possibilities of a corona virus that
will continue to spread through the
summer and even if it doesn't there
isn't a substantial outbreak in Japan
the effects the but there are all sorts
of ways in which this Olympics like
every other Olympics the 1896 Athens
Olympic was plagued with controversy
about the financing and the location the
behavior of the American fans the
Olympics seemed to be raised the
question constant why is it worth it why
does anybody want to do it what does it
is it really worth the cost the social
the political the economic environmental
environmental cost the IOC is used to
this the IOC roll out appeals to
Olympism with every criticism that is
lobbed at them or at or at the host city
I think though there's another way of
thinking about the possibilities and the
problems of the Olympic movement and
what in this instance the Tokyo 2020 is
is apt to bring Olympism interacts with
the Olympic brand in rather more
complicated ways than sheer hypocrisy
because the IOC has invested so much
over so much so much time in the
ceremony and the pageantry and the
symbolism of Olympism as a as a
philosophy as a set of claims it creates
conditions of its own in a sense self
entrapment it can be and actually has
been forced to live up to the rhetoric
of its philosophy the new emphasis on
sustainability the new efforts to
include trans
athletes the efforts to require host
cities particularly after the Sochi
Winter Olympics to demonstrate and to be
accountable for diversity not just in
the athletes population but also in
media access and in the treatment of
visitors all of these are ways in which
people can use not the vices that
critics uncover about the Olympics but
the virtues that the IOC itself claim to
represent through these this this
sporting pageantry let me give you you
know three examples here at the end of
this kind of rhetorical self entrapment
that is a way in which in fact the
Olympics they might not be worth it but
there are ways in which they can be
leveraged for progressive movement as I
said women females have been brought in
as athletes into the Olympic Games
especially from the 1960s on but that
has raised the question forced the IOC
to make determinations about exactly who
is not who is a female but who was an
Olympic female who is a female for the
purposes of dividing events into men's
events and women's events and if any of
you follow this you know that from
anatomical inspections that was the
standard in the 1960s where female
athletes under under question would have
to prevent parade naked in front of a
panel of doctors and officials to
determine by sight if they were male or
female to more molecular or cellular and
now endocrinology chol investigations
into levels that would determine the
line between male and female every in
which this has been measured has been
proven to be a dubious and unsupportable
the Olympics have been probably
the most public platform we have for
undermining the surety of a sex binary
now the end result may not be the giving
up a distinction between male sports and
female sports and coming up with other
ways of classifying athletes to create
equal competitions but one can imagine
that in fact there will be continual
challenges to this sense of a
male-female divide as it has been used
to as it has been used to to preserve
this style of athletics a second way in
which the Olympics by the sheer force of
their scale have provided have
undermined some of our authorities is in
again there's human bodies and their
athletes bodies there are so many sports
in the Olympics with all different kinds
of instruments and technologies and and
and human activities that this whole
line between the human body and its
artificial assemblages and and
instruments if it doesn't disappear it's
continually disrupted by these efforts
to to effort suit to rule the horse does
not receive a medal in the Olympics yet
but equestrian events who is the athlete
here is it is it is it the horse is it
the rider or is it some cyborg e'en
combination of the two yes this is an
archer who is pulling a bow and
releasing an arrow but if you're doing
that hundreds of times a day day after
day year after year where does the body
end and the instrument begin what is the
thing that is the archer if it does not
include at least parts of the arc
tree racing I mean somehow this is the
medium between the human body and the
water below but the skull is as much a
part I mean this isn't the entity is not
the individual body the entity is this
racing spell and the humans and the ores
and and the skull itself that form that
which is competing against other similar
units the sports have a way at the point
is the sports have a way of raising
questions about what we assume to be
inviolable boundaries between that which
is human that which is that which is
artificial I mean Paul erect live once
the the the world record-holder as a
marathoner I mean these are are they
accessories or do they make the marathon
as a sports as a particularly the
Olympics particularly the particular
qualities of the Olympics encoding this
in a philosophy I'm having multiple
sports on display at the same time raise
these questions about the boundaries or
the lack of boundaries of the of the
human body this is true particularly for
paraplegic athletes the notorious Oscar
Pistorius one of the first to raise
these questions of should he be running
in the Olympics or the Paralympics he
certainly in fact at one point was
allowed to run in both the Olympics and
the Paralympics are these his legs or
these prosthetics that attach to what's
left of his legs but he's raised really
deep questions about the nature of the
body and it leads thirdly to another way
in which the Olympics or the IOC s
embrace of the Paralympic movement and
bringing the Olympics and the
Paralympics closer and closer together
at this point they're still somewhat
separated but one can imagine a time in
the not-too-distant future when the
games are conjoined into a single
Olympics and we can see we begin to
question
these lines between the abled body and
and and the disabled body because these
are elite athletes performing whether in
a wheelchair or in their special Nike
shoes and to what extent this is a
distinction that can be sustained I
think is seriously challenged by the
ways in which the Olympics are the
Olympics are constructed the Olympics
are performed so these and and and other
these in other controversies reveal to
me that sports and especially the
Olympics have been one of the most
influential public stages for
dramatizing this modern conundrum which
is that for all of our efforts strenuous
and continuous to construct and to
codify and to police the distinctions of
modern life we're equally challenging
and questioning and eroding those very
distinctions the Olympic movement as
I've tried to suggest is unique in the
world of global sports and it's uniquely
powerful for its distinctive qualities
especially it's self-perpetuating
political structure its economic
monopoly on the one hand and its pious
and public professions of Olympism as a
balance of body and mind and spirit as a
balance of effort and execution and
achievement on on the other it's a
contest between the Olympic brand and
the Olympics philosophy and the temporal
structure of the Olympics and the
distributed geography of the hosting
leads each Olympics to strive for this
doubled quality of exemplifying the
generic form of an Olympic Games given
the rigid IOC imposed stipulations and
producing a uniquely memorable and
consequential mega event that's fitting
in and standing out simultaneously and
we can see these twin imperatives in
their nascent form in the 1964 Tokyo
Olympic Games and in their mature form
in the recent Olympics including the
2020 Tokyo games it's tempting to
characterize it's tempting to discount
the crass commercialism and the lofty
idealism as a hypocritical and a
disabling contradiction at the heart of
the Olympic movement but it's also
possible and I think more analytically
productive to see this as a dynamic and
dramatic entanglement that is a mutual
conditioning that has demonstrated the
potential for progressive as well as for
regressive outcomes the Olympics are fun
to watch but to me more valuable they're
good to think and I hope that I've given
you a few provocations this afternoon
that will sustain you through the
sometimes tedious hours of watching
Madison cycling and for man kayaking
thank you very much
[Applause]
I think there's the time for any
question before we move up to the
reception you up here
well it's a fascinating question it's
important because what's what's
interesting to me is how expositions
were very well developed by ninth by the
1900 Paris Exposition going back to
Crystal Palace in the 1850s and even
before that so in the 19th century it
was this this World Exposition or
industrial fairs that was the template
for this kind of gathering to display
the fruits of Technology and culture
bringing you know through the Imperial
Circus in most cases but still the
Chicago exposition in the 1890 the
interesting thing is how expositions
they haven't died out but they never
gained the kind of organizational
strength and sort of sustaining that the
Olympic Games came the Olympic Games
were to the 20th century
what expositions were to the 19th
century the expositions continue as they
say but in fact Osaka having lost out
its opportunity to bid for the for the
Olympics in Japan has turned around a
bid for in Shanghai did the same thing
for its exposition so the expositions
have become sort of backups to that to
the games but they've lost their power
as the venue for perform for bringing
the world's nations and peoples and
economies together and and Paris was
that moment sort of because in fact the
exposition was more important than the
Olympics and the Olympic Games were
spread out through the months of the
exposition and there were some people
who came to participate and they
didn't even know they're participating
in the Olympics and there was an
American athlete who months later got a
medal in the mail and didn't know what
it was because she had won a medal but
nobody had ever told her so there it was
something of an afterthought but very
quickly it became the dominant and the
exposition the subordinate
we're safe and that's why of all the
games the Olympics are the most sought I
mean for the World Cup you know all you
need is to refurbish your national
stadium and you build a couple soccer
stadiums around the country but Tokyo's
got 33 different sports I mean the
venues and then they'd be connections
among the venues and the housing of
10,000 athletes rather than 800 soccer
players this is the scale of the
Olympics speak to your point about it
being you know both the planners dream
and a planners nightmare but in any case
it's that cover for agendas that were
long in play I mean the bullet train had
been planned really since the 30s but in
the 1950s and it languished because of
the scale of the budget required along
comes the Olympics and it became the
highest priority we have to finish that
sync on said no matter what so yes
planners people may not but planners
love the Olympics
[Music]
well first of the I mean the three
different agendas I was talking about
are deeply political every single one of
them and so the as you say the rhetoric
is fascinating I mean to the insistence
that the games are deep political is an
intensely political statement it's that
you know our politics count the politics
of the IOC but the politics of the
individual athletes don't but this in
again this 1896 these issues of the
political significance of the order of
the countries that were launching into
the stadium was played out so it is it's
built into and the more ceremony that is
added to the Olympics the more platforms
you have for political expression the
the torch relay in China before the
Beijing Olympics in 2008 is a good
example or the torch relay in 1964 that
went through Southeast Asia and then
Taiwan and then Okinawa before coming to
the mainland was transparently
political move by the planner so I mean
that's why the IOC with a straight face
can say things like that I mean every
Brundage was there was there was a
racist anti-semitic I mean to say
something like that it's just it's so
transparently false that it is almost
beside the point of the politics of the
Olympics that are built in as I said at
every level and in the upcoming 2020
those are some of the politics the East
Asia frictions this national debate
about where resources should be should
be directed and how Tokyo has to
reposition itself to maintain its global
standing and disability I mean the the
NGOs and the ampère's are very
effectively using politics in order to
to push the Olympics to invest in making
Tokyo more accessible and more barrier
free I mean that's a very productive
political struggle that's been going on
for a number of years
that's probably I mean again the IOC is
not transparent enough to know for sure
but it was probably NBC the major
licensee that insisted that they needed
the August audience as opposed to the
fall audience up to actually Rome 1960
they were also worried about the summer
heat in Rome and they moved that to the
fall and so Tokyo originally was
supposed to do it in July but petitioned
to have it in October but actually
October 10th the Summer Olympics but by
2020 the broadcasting revenues are so
important that they're going to force
the athletes these 11,000 athletes to
perform in the heat and humidity of
Tokyo and late July and of course you
know you saw the picture of in
photographs those of you go to Japan of
the preliminary events and the
tournaments they had last summer
we're appalling I mean even they
shortened the races they have moved the
marathon which is from again from 1896
was the IQs the iconic event of the
Olympics always held on the last day the
Tokyo marathon of course sponsored by
the Metropolitan subway system because
the route runs along on the major subway
routes it's a way of advertising the
Tokyo Metropolitan subway and so when
the IOC forced the Japanese the
organising committee to move the
marathon from Tokyo up to Sapporo this
was a major shock mean albedo hey
everybody lobby the IOC to keep the
marathon they would run it at 2 o'clock
in the morning they would do anything to
keep it in Tokyo but the marathon is one
of the few events that has been for
those reasons moved
so but if anyone was in supporter last
summer it was brutal I mean it was over
a hundred for days and days so I'm not
sure that moving into Sapporo is
necessarily going to solve their problem
I'm sorry what any well like many polls
about controversial issues both sides
have generated because again the IOC
part of its stipulations for bidding is
to demonstrate not just official
interest but public support local public
support and so these bid packages that
well this year they reduce the price but
it costs six hundred and fifty thousand
US dollars to bid for the Olympics and
included demands that extensive public
polling be demonstrate local support but
the opposition in Vancouver and Tokyo
have also come up with polls to
demonstrate the opposite so it's
difficult to you know to judge the
validity of these competing polls that
seek to you know to test and to use
local opinion for both sides and Tokyo
was really split on that issue Boston of
course when when when it was her folks
for Boston I mean I was actually through
a referendum but the polling there was
used to generate significant opposition
yeah
it's a good question of course I mean if
you are one of those people who are
interested in the sports of the Olympics
as well as everything else
I mean you will know that there's many
Olympics as there are countries and the
distribution of broadcasting fees now
allow every country to create its own
Olympics and so you know the Olympics
that is produced by CBC in Canada
they're very different than the Olympics
produced by NBC are produced by by
Argentine State a television and so the
events that one pays attention to are
often shaped by what is decided by the
national boss so there's a
nationalization of this transnational
experience that's quite interesting and
changes from from Olympics to Olympics I
mean I think I mean to me these issues
of of the body in the ends of the body
or the endless body I mean is this
biotechnical entity that our athletes is
but particularly fascinating and those
those kinds of sports sailing is another
example the I mean the issues of gender
or sex determination and the
indeterminacy of sex determination you
know or certainly have been litigated
most extensively in track and field and
issues of the abled and the disabled
have also been litigated most publicly
in issues of track and field so in
thinking about those issues those are
the kinds of sports that have been have
had the most powerful that's a
demonstration effect for forcing us you
know to rethink to destabilize
these kinds of contrasts
[Applause]
[Music]